from all corners of this kingdom
they are coming with purpose
and provisions
chicken sandwiches we are choosing a new
crisp
belgian chocolate cookies a little munch
in the queue from dominique's kitchen in
witness
to paula's back garden in prestatin yeah
so we had lots of buntin everywhere um
we had blooms up it was only june when
the platinum jubilee party here was in
full swing the queen made her appearance
she was just here
in full vision and she had two little
corgis with her
now paula and her daughter
just want to go to london
and say thank you
she wasn't with me at the time when i
was in the mall in 2002 she was actually
an assignment to me not knowing i was
loving a boy or a girl at the time
so to take her with me 20 years later
for a different occasion a more somber
occasion but
for a royal occasion
it's your family and it's their family
yeah
they'll be up early the coach pickups
along this stretch of the north wales
coastline start at 2 15 a.m but geraint
is all set
it is the headline of of this century i
would have thought it's you know you
don't
you're not involved in this every day
and
some way shape or form everybody is
involved
on t side ben has just sorted his train
it's a trip he's making on behalf of his
mum
my mother was a massive supporter of the
queen she's no longer with us and i feel
that it's an opportunity to make her
part of this moment as well you could
say that part of the glue of society has
come a little bit unstuck
and it's brought the country together
to reassess where we go from here
back in witness there's another train to
catch i mean i think it's truly what
makes us british old monarchy yeah
you seem quite up by it today yeah
yeah yeah totally yeah
yeah uh
i mean i would i would have got it any
way i could have
all this has actually moved people and
for however long it lasts right now this
country feels like a more united kingdom
and that
is quite a legacy
i am feeling
i am so glad we're here so we found the
end
they see it as their duty
to take a place
in their nation's story
tom parmenter sky news